Professor Paul Bloom:
I'm delighted to introduce the
first guest lecturer for this
Introduction to Psychology
course, Dean Peter Salovey.
Peter is an old friend and
colleague.
Many of you--I think everybody
here knows of him through his
role as Dean of Yale College.
I'll just, in this context of
this introduction,
mention two other things about
him.
One is prior to being dean and
in fact, still as a dean,
he's an active scientist and in
particular,
a social psychologist actively
involved in studying health
psychology, the proper use of
psychological methods to frame
health messages,
and also is the founder and
developer of the idea of
emotional intelligence,
an idea he's done a huge amount
of research on.
Secondly, Peter is or was an
active and extremely well-known
teacher at Yale College.
He taught at one point,
the largest course ever in Yale
College – a course on
Psychology in Law which broke
every record ever had here.
And before that,
during that,
and after that,
he was a legendary Introduction
to Psychology teacher.
And I think--and he had some
reason for why he was so
legendary with his lecture today
on the topic of love.
[applause]
Dean Peter Salovey:
Thanks very much.
Okay.
Thank you very much,
Professor Bloom.
It really is a pleasure to come
and lecture to you today on
Valentine's Day on the topic of
love.
My main area of research is
human emotion.
And love is an emotion.
It's not one that I study
personally, at least not in the
lab, and--but it is fun to talk
about.
And it is a topic that lends
itself to many social
psychological phenomena.
It's also great to be able to
come in and guest lecture.
One of the things I very much
miss since serving as dean is
the opportunity to teach
Psychology 110.
And although I love being dean,
I do miss teaching Introductory
Psychology, the feeling of
exposing people to ideas that
maybe you hadn't heard before.
Well, I suspect some of the
ideas in this talk you'll have
not heard before and for a
variety of reasons.
A couple of the things you'll
notice is that some of the
experiments I'll talk about
today are not the kinds of
experiments that can be done
anymore.
They're not considered
ethically acceptable but they
were done in the ‘50s and
‘60s and early ‘70s when
ethical standards were different
and so we can teach them.
We just can't give you the same
experiences that some of the
college students that we'll talk
about today in these studies
had.
The other thing I will mention
is that there is a certain
androcentric and heterosexual
quality to much of the social
psychological research on
romantic love.
You'll see that in the
experiments.
Usually, the participants are
men and usually the targets are
women in these experiments.
I'm not endorsing this as the
only way to study love.
It just happens to be the way
these experiments were done and
so I mention this caution right
from the beginning.
We'll have to think about--One
of the things you should think
about is do you think these
experiments generalized to other
kinds of dyadic relationships.
And that's a question that I
think you can ask throughout
this lecture.
Okay.
So let's get started.
And to start things off I think
what we need to do is consider a
definition.
I'm going to define what love
is but then most of the
experiments I'm going to talk
about are really focused more on
attraction than love--who finds
each other of romantic interest
that might then develop into a
love relationship.
But let's start with a
definition of love.
And I'm going to pick a
definition from a former
colleague, Robert Sternberg,
who is now the dean at Tufts
University but was here on our
faculty at Yale for nearly
thirty years or so.
And he has a theory of love
that argues that it's made up of
three components:
intimacy,
passion, and commitment,
or what is sometimes called
decision commitment.
And these are relatively
straightforward.
He argued that you don't have
love if you don't have all three
of these elements.
Intimacy is the feeling of
closeness, of connectedness with
someone, of bonding.
Operationally,
you could think of intimacy as
you share secrets,
you share information with this
person that you don't share with
anybody else.
Okay.
That's really what intimacy is,
the bond that comes from
sharing information that isn't
shared with other--with many
other people.
Second element is passion.
Passion is what you think it is.
Passion is the--we would say
the drive that leads to romance.
You can think of it as physical
attraction or sex.
And Sternberg argues that this
is a required component of a
love relationship.
It is not, however,
a required component of taking
a shower in Calhoun College.
[laughter]
The third element of love in
Sternberg's theory is what he
calls decision or commitment,
the decision that one is in a
love relationship,
the willingness to label it as
such,
and a commitment to maintain
that relationship at least for
some period of time.
Sternberg would argue it's not
love if you don't call it love
and if you don't have some
desire to maintain the
relationship.
So if you have all three of
these, intimacy,
passion and commitment,
in Sternberg's theory you have
love.
Now what's interesting about
the theory is what do you have
if you only have one out of
three or two out of three?
What do you have and how is it
different if you have a
different two out of three?
These are--What's interesting
about this kind of theorizing is
it give--it gives rise to many
different permutations that when
you break them down and start to
look at them carefully can be
quite interesting.
So what I've done is I've taken
Sternberg's three elements of
love, intimacy,
passion and commitment,
and I've listed out the
different kinds of relationships
one would have if you had zero,
one, two or three out of the
three elements.
And I'm using names or types
that Sternberg uses in his
theory.
These are really from him.
Some of these are pretty
obvious.
If you don't have intimacy,
if you don't have passion,
if you don't have commitment,
you don't have love.
Sternberg calls this non-love.
That's the technical term.
And [laughs]
essentially what he's saying is
the relationship you now have to
the person sitting next to you,
presuming that you're sitting
next to a random person that you
didn't know from your college,
is probably non-love.
If it's something else,
we could talk about it at the
end of the lecture or perhaps
when I get to it in a moment.
Now let's start to add elements.
Let's add intimacy.
This is sharing secrets,
a feeling of closeness,
connectedness,
bonding.
Let's say we have that with
someone but we don't have
passion, that is,
no sexual arousal,
and no commitment to maintain
the relationship.
This is liking.
Sternberg calls it liking.
And liking is really what is
happening in most typical
friendships, not your closest
friendship but friendships of a
casual kind.
You feel close,
you share certain information
with that person that you don't
share with other--many other
people,
but you're not physically
attracted and there's no
particular commitment to
maintaining this for a long
period of time.
Now, what if you're not
intimate, you're not committed,
but you're passionate;
you feel that sexual arousal.
This is what Sternberg would
call infatuation.
And that term probably works
for you too, infatuated love,
and this is love at first
sight.
"I don't know you,
we've never shared any secrets
because I don't know you,
I'm not committed to defining
this as anything,
I'm not committed to the future.
In fact, I'm not thinking about
the future.
I'm thinking about right now
but boy, am I attracted."
Right.
That's infatuation and that's
what Sternberg means by
infatuated love.
The third kind of one-element
relationship is there's no
intimacy, right,
no bonding,
no closeness,
no secrets, no physical
attraction, no sexual arousal,
but by gosh,
we are going to maintain this
relationship,
we are committed to it for all
time.
Sternberg calls that "empty
love."
Empty love is kind of
interesting.
It's often the final stage of
long-term relationships that
have gone bad.
"We don't share information
with each other anymore so
there's no intimacy.
We don't feel physically
attracted to each other anymore,
there's no passion,
but we'd better stay together
for the kids,
right?
Or we've got to stay together
for appearance's sake or we'd
better stay together because
financially it would be a
disaster if we don't" or all of
the reasons other than intimacy
and passion that people might
commit to each other.
That's what Sternberg calls
empty love.
Now what's interesting is in
societies where marriages are
arranged this is often the first
stage of a love relationship.
These two people who have maybe
never seen each other before,
who have never shared secrets
so there's no intimacy,
who have never--don't know if
they're physically attracted to
each other or on their wedding
day revealed to each other and
committed legally and sometimes
religiously to each other.
Right?
The commitment is there but at
that moment nothing else might
be there.
What's interesting of course is
that such relationships don't
seem to have any greater chance
of ending in divorce than people
who marry for love.
But there's a big confound,
there's a big problem in
studies of those kind of
relationships.
What might it be?
Anybody.
What might be the problem in
the statement I just made that
these kind of relationships are
just as likely to survive as
people who marry for love?
Yes.
Student:
[inaudible]
Dean Peter Salovey:
Yeah.
So they may occur;
they're more likely to occur in
societies that frown on divorce.
They make it very costly,
socially costly,
to divorce, so then they stay
together for all kinds of
reasons, not always such good
ones.
All right.
Now who was it who sang the
song "Two Out of Three Ain't
Bad"?
Was that Meat Loaf?
Who was it?
It was Meat Loaf.
All right.
Professor Bloom says it was
Meat Loaf.
It was Meat Loaf.
You're all saying,
"there was a singer called Meat
Loaf?"
Meat Loaf sang the song "Two
Out of Three Ain't Bad."
Let's see if two out of three
ain't bad.
What if you have intimacy,
"we share secrets,
passion, we feel physically
attracted to each other but
we're not making any commitments
here."
Sternberg calls that "romantic
love."
This is physical attraction
with close bonding but no
commitment, Romeo and Juliet
when they first met.
This is often the way
relationships start:
"We like each other,
I'm physically attracted to
each other,
I--to you, I enjoy spending
time with you but I'm not making
any long-term commitments.
So I'm not even willing to use
the ‘L' word in describing
what it is we have."
Right?
Many of you might have been in
relationships of this sort.
That's romance.
That's romantic love.
Now, what if you have intimacy,
"we share secrets with each
other, but there's no particular
physical attraction but we are
really committed to this
relationship."
This is what Sternberg calls
"companionate love."
This is your best friend.
"We are committed to sharing
intimacy, to being friends
forever," but physical
attraction is not part of the
equation here.
This is sort of the--maybe the
Greek ideal in relationships of
some kind.
All right.
What if we have passion,
"I'm sexually attracted to
you," but no intimacy.
"I don't want to really know
that much about you,
I don't want to really share
anything of me with you,
but I am committed to
maintaining this physical
attraction to you" [laughter]
Well,
that's what Sternberg calls
"fatuous love."
It's a whirlwind courtship.
It's a Hollywood romance.
It might lead to a shotgun
wedding.
Maybe you find yourself in Las
Vegas and you get married for a
day and a half and then realize
that this wasn't such a good
idea.
And maybe your name is Britney
and you're a singer.
[laughter]
Well, anyway,
you've got the idea.
That's fatuous love.
"We are basically committed to
each other for sex" but it's
very hard to make those
relationships last a long time
because we might not have
anything in common,
we might not share anything
with each other,
we might not trust each other,
we are not particularly bonded
to each other.
On the other hand,
if you have all three,
intimacy, passion,
commitment, this is "consummate
love" according to Sternberg –
complete love.
This is how he defines love.
Okay.
So now you have a definition of
love and you can now,
as a homework assignment,
sit down tonight and make a
list of every person you know by
the three elements of love and
just start putting the check
marks in the boxes and tallying
up your personal love box score.
And we don't want to collect
those.
We don't even want to see those
but you can have fun with that.
Then you can ask the other
people to do it too and you can
compare with each other.
[laughter]
And if you all survive this
exercise you'll be better for
it.
[laughter]
What doesn't kill you makes you
stronger.
That's the idea behind that
exercise.
All right.
Now the social psychology of
love really has been a social
psychology of attraction.
What makes people find each
other attractive?
What makes them want to be
intimate?
What makes them physically
desirable to each other?
What might lead to a
commitment, a decision to make a
commitment to make the
relationship last?
This is just so nice.
I'm giving this lecture on love
and the two of you are holding
hands here in the front row.
It's really-- [laughter]
And-- [applause]
All three elements present,
intimacy, passion,
and-- [laughter]
Yeah.
Okay.
[laughter] Good.
Just checking.
[laughter] Okay.
So what's interesting about the
social psychology of attraction
is it has focused on seven
variables.
And I've divided these into two
groups, the big three and the
more interesting four.
And I call them the big--The
big three are three variables
that the effects are so powerful
that they almost don't need to
be discussed in much detail.
The more interesting four are
the ones I'm going to focus on
in this lecture because they're
a bit more subtle and they may
be things that you've never
heard of before.
But let's quickly talk about
the big three.
The way to understand the big
three is with the phrase "all
other things being equal."
All other things being equal,
people who find themselves in
close spatial proximity to each
other,
like sharing an armrest in a
lecture, will be more likely to
be attracted to each other and
form a romantic relationship.
Okay, all other things being
equal.
Now this has been tested in
lots of interesting ways.
Studies have been done in the
city of New York where you
can--if you live in Manhattan
you can actually get a very nice
metric of how far apart people
live from each other in city
blocks.
Right?
You have a nice grid pattern
and you can use a city block
metric to add up the number of
blocks between people's doors.
And people who live more
closely together are more likely
to end up in romantic
relationships with each other.
It seems kind of obvious.
Right?
This even works on college
campuses.
We can measure in feet the
distance between the door to
your room and the door to every
other room of a student on
campus and there will be a
correlation between the
likelihood of--it's a negative
correlation--the likelihood of
getting into a romantic
relationship with a person and
the number of feet between your
door and that person's door.
The fewer feet,
the more likely a romantic
relationship,
all other things being equal.
Now, all other things being
equal is a big qualifier.
Right?
But if we could statistically
control for every other
variable, all I'd need to do is
measure the distance from your
door to everybody else's door on
campus and I could chart out
who's going to fall in love with
whom on the Yale campus.
Now, this idea in a way is--I
don't know.
Maybe it's a little
counterintuitive.
There is a kind of cultural
myth around the stranger,
the person you don't know,
who you will--who you fall in
love with.
And that is not likely to be
the case if it's the person who
is nearby.
Right?
And you'll see as we go through
the other big--the other two
"big three" that there is a kind
of repetition of this theme.
It isn't the stranger you fall
in love with.
All right.
Let's continue down.
Similarity.
You've probably heard the
phrase "Birds of a feather flock
together" and that's true when
it comes to romance.
On any dimension that
psychologists have measured in
these kinds of studies,
when people are more similar
they are more likely to find
each other attractive.
This could be obvious things
like height or age but it also
could be things like attitudes
toward capital punishment,
preference for the Red Sox over
the Yankees.
Right?
All of these are dimensions of
similarity.
All things being equal,
the more similar the more
likely you'll find each other
attractive.
So, opposites don't really
attract.
Birds of a feather may flock
together but opposites don't
really attract each other.
Now, usually at this point
somebody in the lecture hall
raises their hand and says,
"Well, my boyfriend or my
girlfriend and I are complete
opposites and how do you account
for that,
Professor Salovey?"
And I usually look at them and
I say, "Good luck."
[laughter]
And of course all things might
not be equal.
There may be other variables at
play but, all things being
equal, similarity does not breed
contempt.
Similarity breeds attraction.
Okay?
Isn't it interesting?
We have all of these common
sayings that contradict each
other and then empirically,
some of them turn out to have
more evidence supporting them
than others.
So "opposites attract?"
Not much evidence.
"Similarity breeds contempt?"
"Birds of a feather flock
together?"
Yeah, there's some evidence for
that anyway.
Finally, familiarity.
Familiarity--We tend to fall in
love with people in our
environment with whom we are
already familiar.
The idea that some enchanted
evening we will see a
stranger--Where are The New Blue
when you need them?
[laughter]
"Some enchanted evening you
will see a stranger across a
crowded room."
Right?
What musical is that from?
"South Pacific."
Very good.
You will see a stranger across
a crowded room.
That's kind of a cultural myth.
Of course it happens,
but much more common is
somebody you already know,
somebody you have seen
repetitively you suddenly find
attraction--attractive and a
relationship forms.
Okay?
So the big three:
People who are similar to you,
people who are already familiar
to you, people who are nearby in
space.
These are the people,
all things being equal,
that you will find attractive.
Okay?
So those are the big three.
Those are big main effects.
Those are big,
easy to observe in various ways
in the lab.
By the way, the familiarity
idea doesn't just work for
people.
I can show you words in a
language that you don't speak
and I can flash those words to
you very quickly and I can later
repeat some of those words and
mix in some new ones that you've
never seen before and I can say,
"I don't know--I know you don't
know what any of these words
mean.
I know you can't read these
characters but just,
if you had to tell me,
which ones do you like and
which ones don't you like or how
much do you like each one?"
The ones you will like are the
ones you saw earlier,
the ones that you already have
familiarity.
Even if you don't remember
having seen them,
even if that familiarity was
generated with such quick
exposures that you don't
remember even having seen
anything,
you will get that familiarity
effect.
Okay?
Good.
The more interesting four.
These are more interesting
because they're a little bit
complicated, a little bit
subtle.
Let's start with actually the
one that is my favorite.
This is "competence."
Think about other people in
your environment.
Think about people who are
competent.
Generally--And think about
people who are incompetent.
Generally, we are more
attracted to people who seem
competent to us.
Now, that isn't very
interesting.
And it turns out that's not
really the effect.
Yes, we're more attracted to
people who are competent than
people who we think are
incompetent but people who are
super competent,
people who seem competent on
all dimensions,
they're kind of threatening to
us.
They don't make us feel so good
about ourselves.
Right?
They make us feel a bit
diminished by comparison.
So, what we really like--The
kind of person we're really
attracted to is the competent
individual who occasionally
blunders.
And this is called the Pratfall
Effect, that our liking for the
competent person grows when they
make a mistake,
when they do something
embarrassing,
when they have a failure
experience.
Okay?
You can see this with public
figures.
Public figures who are viewed
as competent but who pratfall,
who make a mistake,
sometimes they are even more
popular after the mistake.
Okay?
I think of Bill Clinton when he
was President.
His popularity at the end of
his term, despite what everyone
would agree, whether you like
Bill Clinton or not,
was a big mistake with Monica
Lewinsky, his popularity didn't
suffer very much.
A lot of people in the media
would describe him,
"Well, he's just--It just shows
he's human."
He makes mistakes like the rest
of us, even though that was a
pretty big mistake.
Right?
And you could see this even
with smaller pratfalls.
Sometimes public figures are
liked even more after their
pratfall.
Now, the classic experiment,
the classic pratfall
experiment, is just a beautiful
one to describe.
It's a work of art.
So, let me tell you a little
bit about it.
You're in this experiment.
You're brought to the lab and
you're listening to a tape
recording of interviews with
people who are described as
possible representatives from
your college to appear on a quiz
show.
The quiz show is called
"College Bowl," which I don't
think is on anymore but was on
when I was in college.
And you're listening to
interviews with possible
contestants from Yale who are
going to be on "College Bowl."
You have to decide how
much--What you're told is you
have to decide who should be
chosen to be on "College Bowl."
And you listen to these
interviews.
Now what's interesting is
there's two types of people,
the nearly perfect person and
the mediocre person.
The nearly perfect person
answered 92% of the questions
correctly, admitted modestly to
being a member of the campus
honor society,
was the editor of the yearbook,
and ran varsity track.
That's the nearly perfect
person.
The mediocre person answers
only 30% of the questions
correctly, admits that he has
only average grades,
he worked on the yearbook as a
proofreader, and he tried out
for the track team but didn't
make it.
So, you see,
they're keeping a lot of the
elements consistent but in one
case he's kind of an average
performer and in the other case
nearly perfect.
Now, which of these two people
do you find more attractive in
listening to the tape?
So, when they ask you questions
about which person should be on
the quiz show,
people say the more competent
person.
But they also ask questions
like, "How attractive do you
find this person?"
Now, you're only listening to
an audiotape.
How attractive do you find this
person?
And the results are pretty
obvious.
The competent person is rated
as much more attractive,
considerably more attractive,
than the mediocre person.
Okay?
If this were the end of the
story though,
it would be a kind of boring
story and it's not the end of
the story.
Now, what happens is half of
the participants in the
experiment who have listened to
each of these tapes--You only
get to listen to one tape.
Half of them are assigned to
the blunder condition.
And what happens in the blunder
condition is the tape continues
and what you hear is the
clattering of dishes,
a person saying--the person
saying, "Oh, my goodness.
I've spilled coffee all over my
new suit."
Okay?
That's the blunder.
That's the pratfall.
Now you're asked,
"Who do you find more
attractive?"
And look what happens.
Your rating of the
attractiveness of the competent
person grows even higher.
The competent person who
blunders, this is the person
that I love.
Unfortunately,
the mediocre person who
blunders, you now think is even
more mediocre.
[laughter] Right?
This is the sad irony in these
experiments.
The effect works both ways so
the mediocre become even more
lowered in your esteem,
in your regard.
Now, I'll tell you a little
personal story about my coming
to Yale that relates to this
experiment.
This is one of the most famous
experiments in the history of
social psychology.
I wouldn't quite put it up
there.
You'll hear maybe later about,
or maybe you've already about
Milgram and maybe Asch
conformity and maybe Robber's
Cave.
Those are even better known
than this, but this is right up
there.
This is a top five experiment.
What--So--And it was done by
Elliot Aronson who has retired
now, but for many years taught
at the University of California
at Santa Cruz.
The name is not one that you
need to know.
In any case,
I came to Yale in 1981 as a
graduate student and I was
looking for an adviser and I was
kind of interviewing with a
faculty member at Yale at the
time named Judy Rodin.
Some of you may know that name
because she went on later to
become the President of the
University of Pennsylvania and
now is the President of the
Rockefeller Foundation.
But I was interviewing with her
and set up a meeting.
And what I was trying to
persuade her in this meeting was
to take me on as one of her
students, to let--to be my
adviser.
And it's about my third or
fourth week of graduate school
and I'm pretty nervous about
this.
And she could be intimidating
to a first-year graduate
student.
And I remember I was holding
this mug of coffee and I was
pleading with her,
trying to convince her to take
me on as her student,
and I was saying,
"Judy,
I'll get a lot done.
I'll work really hard.
I can analyze data.
I can write."
And I'm talking about myself
and I'm swinging--I'm using my
hands as I talk.
I'm swinging this cup of coffee
around.
And fairly soon into the
conversation I demonstrated some
principle that you've probably
learned in your physics class
having to do with an object at
rest remaining at rest unless
acted upon by a force.
Well, the object at rest was
the coffee in the cup and when I
pulled the coffee cup out from
under the coffee it landed right
on her desk and began--I watched
in slow motion as this wave of
coffee just moved from my side
of the desk to her side of the
desk.
She jumped up and jumped back
and started moving papers around
and really was giving me this
look like "Why don't you just
leave?"
So, I was trying to save the
moment as best as I could,
and I looked at her and I said,
"Judy, do you remember that old
experiment that Elliot Aronson
did [laughter]
on attractiveness?"
[laughter]
She looked at me kind of out of
the corner of her eye and I
said, "Well, that was my
blunder.
[laughter]
Now you're going to like me
even more."
[laughter]
And she just shook her head and
she said, "Peter,
Peter, Peter.
You know that effect only works
if I think you're competent
first."
[laughter]
Anyway, that was my
introduction to Yale,
graduate school at Yale.
[laughter] All right.
So blundering.
Only blunder if you're
competent first and it will make
you more attractive.
That is the Pratfall Effect.
Let's move on and I'm going to
move a little bit quickly
through all this because I want
to leave time for a few
questions at the end of the
lecture.
Let's talk about physical
attractiveness as number two of
the more interesting four.
Now physical attractiveness is
one that really bothers us.
We don't like to believe that
physical attractiveness accounts
for much in life.
It seems unfair.
Except at the margins,
there isn't much we can do
about physical attractiveness.
And when we're not pictured in
The Rumpus it can really
hurt.
[laughter]
So, we all like to believe that
physical attractiveness matters.
And the interesting thing is if
you do surveys of college
students and you say to them,
"Rate how important different
characteristics are in
relationships that you might be
involved in,"
they will say that warmth is
important, sensitivity is
important, intelligence is
important,
compassion is important,
a sense of humor is important,
and they'll say that looks
aren't important.
But if you measure all of those
things--Let's do it in a
different order.
If you send everybody out on a
blind date and then you look at,
after the blind date,
how many of those people who
are matched up blindly actually
go on a second date,
actually get together again,
what predicts who gets together
again?
Was it the rating of warmth?
No.
Sensitivity?
Intelligence?
No.
Compassion?
Sense of humor?
No.
What was it?
Looks.
So we believe that looks don't
matter and unfortunately they
do.
Now, the good news in all of
this is the studies that looked
at physical attractiveness in
this way were just looking at
what predicts a second date
after a first date.
Obviously, what predicts a
long-term relationship are
probably things less superficial
than looks, or at least other
things in addition to looks.
But it is a great predictor of
a second date.
And college students year after
year say, "But it's not
important."
And it's one of those classic
disassociations between what we
think is unimportant and what
empirically turns out to be more
important.
Alright well,
there are very interesting
studies that have been done with
physical attractiveness.
At the University of Minnesota,
a computer algorithm paired
people up.
It couldn't have been a very
complicated algorithm because it
basically paired people up
randomly on the campus.
But the computer--but a lot of
data about all the students on
campus were--was collected--were
collected and people were then
randomly paired up and sent to
the dance.
And then they were tracked over
time.
And just as in the thought
experiment I just gave you,
the University of Minnesota
students acted in the same way.
If the computer--If they rated
their partner as attractive,
the randomly assigned partner,
they were more likely to
continue the relationship.
Now it's interesting to ask,
"why?"
And we have to start to look at
other experiments to try to get
at what is it about physical
attractiveness that makes people
want to pursue the relationship?
And once again Elliot Aronson,
the person who did the blunder
experiment, the "Pratfall"
experiment, he did some nice
work on attractiveness as well.
And in one experiment,
which many people know as the
"Frizzy Wig" experiment,
he did the following.
He invited a confederate,
a graduate student who was
working with him in his
lab--Psychologists--Social
psychologists always call people
who are in the employ of the
experimenter "confederates."
It doesn't mean that they grew
up south of the Mason-Dixon Line
or wave a certain kind of flag
or--but the older term for it
was "stooge."
They would say,
"We hired a stooge to act in
the following role in the
experiment."
But I think a certain
generation of college students
thought stooges were only named
Moe,
Larry, and Curly and so they
started to use the phrase
"confederate."
Now, they'll usually just say,
"We hired an actor."
But anyway, the confederate
that they hired was a woman who
was naturally attractive in most
people's view but they made her
look either more attractive or
less attractive by giving her
kind of frumpy clothes,
bad make-up, and a frizzy wig.
And it was the frizzy wig that
everybody remembers from this
experiment.
And what she does in the
experiment is she poses as a
graduate student in clinical
psychology who is interviewing
male participants – only men
in this experiment.
And at the end of the interview
she gives them her own personal
clinical evaluation of their
personality.
Okay?
So, that's all it is.
They have this interview with
this woman.
She's either made to look very
good or she's made to look kind
of ugly with this frizzy wig and
they talk to her.
She gives them an evaluation of
their personality.
Half of the subjects receive a
favorable personality
assessment.
Half of them receive a kind of
unfavorable evaluation.
How do they respond?
Well, when she was made to look
attractive they were delighted
when she gave them positive
feedback about themselves.
When she was made to--When she
gave--When she was made to look
attractive but gave them
unfavorable information about
themselves,
they were really upset about it.
When she was made to look
unattractive they didn't really
care what kind of information
she gave.
It didn't really matter whether
it was positive or not.
It didn't really make any
difference.
It was interesting.
In the condition where she was
made to look attractive but gave
you bad feedback about yourself,
often the subjects in that
condition would look for an
opportunity to interact with her
in the future,
obviously to try to prove that
her evaluation was wrong.
It mattered that much to them.
So there's kind of this idea
that attractive people,
their feedback to us has more
impact.
I'm not saying this is fair,
I'm not saying it's rational,
I'm not endorsing it,
but empirically-- excuse
me--empirically we can see it,
that somehow the
attractive--the feedback from
the attractive person matters
more to us.
Okay.
Number three of the more
interesting four.
Gain, loss.
This is really a general idea
in psychology that we are in a
way wired up to be more
sensitive to change than to
steady states.
And you could imagine why that
might be true.
Change often signals danger or
opportunity and if we are
especially tuned-in to change,
it helps us survive and it
helps us pass along our genes.
Okay?
So we're more sensitive to
change.
How does that play out in love?
Well, in love we are--what is
very powerful to us is not just
that someone always is positive
toward us,
"I love you,
I love you, I love you,
I love you, I love --" Right?
It wears out its welcome.
What's more powerful is the
person who was not that positive
to us but over time becomes more
positive.
The first derivative of their
regard for us is positive.
Okay?
Aronson calls this the "Gain
Effect."
We are really attracted to
people whose regard for us is
gaining momentum over time.
Okay?
And even if over a period of
time the average amount of their
regard is lower because they
started lower and then got
higher than someone who was
always high,
it's the ones who were first
lower who then went up that
capture our attention.
The first derivative is more
important than just the position
of their regard for us,
getting better and better.
Now, what's interesting is
there is also a loss effect.
People who really hurt us are
not the people who have always
been negative.
The person who every time they
sees you hates you,
says they hate you and
accompanies it with an obscene
gesture--after a while this
person can't hurt you.
Right?
There's a country song that
Ricky Skaggs sings that has the
phrase in it "Nothing can hurt
you like the person you love."
That's what hurts,
the person who always was
positive who now--whose regard
starts to fade.
Oh.
You can only hurt the one you
love.
Right?
You can only hurt the one you
love because you are expecting
positive feedback from the one
you love.
And when that turns negative,
it's a blow.
It's a blow to the solar plexus.
Right?
So you can only hurt the one
you can love but the one who
always loves you sometimes has
trouble showing you that they
love you.
The one who didn't really love
you that much but then starts to
show you that they love you,
that person is a powerful
influence on your behavior.
Okay.
The last--Oops.
Come back.
The last set of studies--Have
you talked about Schacter,
Singer's "Emotions"?
Okay.
So let me describe to you this
phenomenon.
This is a phenomenon about the
misattribution for the causes of
arousal.
You feel physiologically
aroused but you're not
completely sure why,
and you have to make up an
explanation for it.
I think what I want to do--And
sometimes that explanation is
accurate, but the ones that are
interesting here are the ones
where you misattribute the cause
of the arousal--you make a
mistake and think it's love when
it might be due to something
else.
So, let's do a thought
experiment.
I'm a Yale college student,
for the purposes of this
thought experiment and I live in
Pierson because I need to walk a
great distance to Chapel Street,
to the Starbuck's on Chapel
Street.
And I have a friend who I don't
know that well,
somebody who was sitting next
to me in class a few weeks in a
row.
And I said, "Would you like to
go see The New Blue in concert
and then get coffee after it
Friday night?"
And she says to me, "Sure.
I would do that."
And so The New Blue concert
takes place in the
Pierson-Davenport Theater in the
basement there – what used to
be a squash court is now a
little theater – and we enjoy
ourselves at the concert and
then I say,
"Let's go to Starbuck's and get
a coffee."
And so, we walk that distance
from Pierson College down to the
York Street Gate,
over to Chapel Street,
make the left on Chapel Street,
another block down to High,
walk into the Starbuck's.
And she says to me,
"You know, I'd better have a
decaf because it's kind of late
and I want to be able to sleep."
And I say, "That's fine.
Whatever you want."
She says, "Yeah.
So I'll have a decaf double
espresso mocha skinny with a--"
What?
What other dimensions are there?
[laughter] Right?
"A double espresso mocha skinny
frothed."
[laughter] And I say, "Okay.
Fine.
I'll have a coffee."
[laughter]
And I go up there and I order
the drinks.
"I'll have a small coffee
please and a double espresso
mocha skinny frothed" except the
barista makes a mistake.
Did the word "barista" exist
before Starbuck's?
[laughter] I don't think so.
The barista makes a mistake.
The barista uses caffeinated
coffee in the drink instead of
decaf, doesn't tell anybody,
doesn't tell me.
I don't see it.
I just come back with my black
coffee and my double espresso
mocha latte skinny frothed,
except it isn't espresso.
It's got two shots of
caffeinated espresso.
I'm sorry.
It isn't decaffeinated.
It's got two shots of
caffeinated espresso in it.
And I put it down on the table
and we're having this nice
conversation and we're drinking
our beverages and it's about
12:30/1:00 now and Starbuck's is
closing and it's time to walk
back to Pierson.
And we're walking back to
Pierson and we leave the
Starbuck's, we make a left on
Chapel Street,
we're walking up to York,
I'm getting a little sleepy,
but my friend looks at me and
says,
"Huh.
I feel a little funny."
What's actually happening?
Her heart is beating a little
faster, her palms are beginning
to sweat, her breath is coming a
little shorter than it otherwise
would.
"I don't know.
Is it warm in here?"
And she said,
"I don't think I've felt this
way in a very long time.
[laughter] "Gee.
It couldn't be the coffee.
I ordered decaf.
What could this be?
What.."
And she turns and she looks at
me [laughter]
and she says,
"What a day this has been.
What a rare mood I'm in.
Why, it's almost like being in
love."
[laughter]
And it is almost like being in
love except what it really is is
two shots of caffeinated
espresso [laughter]
causing a rapid heart rate,
an increase in respiration,
sweaty palms,
but I don't realize--she
doesn't realize that's what it
is.
She turns to the most
salient--and this is the way
social psychologists would say
it--turns to the most salient
object in her immediate social
environment--that would be
me--and [laughter]
says she's in love.
That's the idea of
misattribution--aroused due to
something else,
"don't know what that is."
It's best if you don't know
what that is or even if you do
mistakenly attribute it,
misattribute it,
to physical attraction,
romance, intimacy,
passion and commitment,
it's love.
All right.
Now, I don't necessarily
recommend that you do this
thought experiment in vivo this
weekend,
although if you're lonely you
might want to try it but
[laughter]
we can go--we can take this
idea right--We can actually do
research on this.
We could take it into the lab.
But before I tell you about lab
experiments let me tell you
about the most famous field
experiment on this idea.
We call this the "Rickety
Bridge" experiment.
And there is a bridge at the
University of British Columbia
that crosses a river that runs
through campus and the
rickety--There's actually two
bridges.
The rickety bridge is one
that's kind of a rope bridge.
It's hundreds of feet above the
river.
It sways in the breeze.
It's only about three feet wide.
You kind of hold on to it
carefully and you cross the
river.
It's a pretty scary way to
cross that river.
Has anybody been--seen this
bridge?
It's still there.
Yes.
You know this bridge.
Okay.
There's another way to cross
the river.
It's on a low bridge near the
water, solid wood planks,
nice and wide,
hand railings made out of solid
wood, and you can cross the
bridge that way.
So, what two investigators at
the University of British
Columbia did is they simply
positioned,
once again, an attractive actor
or confederate on one side of
the bridge.
She was a woman and she met men
crossing the bridge.
And she would intercept them as
they came across the rickety
bridge, or the low bridge,
and she would ask them a few
questions and conclude with,
"Can you write me a story?
You would help me out with my
experiment if you'd just write a
little story right now."
Then she would collect their
story and she would say,
"If you have any questions
about this experiment,
here is my phone number."
Actually, this happens when
you're in experiments.
You get the phone number of the
experimenter.
What happens?
Well, the men,
male students,
who cross the rickety bridge,
they wrote these sexy stories
with interesting content,
with kind of little bit ribald
themes.
And the people on the solid
bridge, they just wrote pretty
boring stories.
The people who crossed the
rickety bridge were more likely
to call her up later and say,
"Yeah.
I'd like to talk about that
experiment I was in.
Could we meet at the Starbuck's?
[laughter]
You drink decaf,
don't you?"
Right?
And the people on the low
bridge were much less likely to
call her up.
Okay?
What was going on?
Well, this was interpreted as
misattributed arousal.
On the rickety bridge you're
swaying in the breeze hundreds
of feet above the water,
the bridge seems unstable.
Maybe you'll make it.
Maybe you won't.
Your heart is beating,
your palms are sweating,
you're breathing harder.
You meet this person and she
seems more attractive because
you're feeling all these things.
And you attribute it to the
attraction.
Now, there's a reason why this
study is bad science.
There's a major flaw in this
study.
The clue to the flaw is that
you can't even call this study
an experiment.
What's the flaw?
Anybody.
Yes.
Student: The people who
would take the rickety bridge
might be more likely to be more
[inaudible]
Dean Peter Salovey:
People who take the rickety
bridge might be the kind of
people who are more looking for
adventure than the people who
take the solid bridge.
Right.
Another way of saying it is
there isn't random assignment of
the subjects to the two
conditions in the study.
That's no random assignment;
it's not an experiment.
You--By not randomly assigning
people to these two conditions,
you may be capturing just
individual differences in the
kind of person who,
when there's a perfectly
stable, safe,
low bridge, says,
"Huh uh.
I won't want to go on that
bridge.
I want to go on the bridge
where I have to risk my life to
get to class."
[laughter]
And then should it surprise us
that that's the kind of person
who would call a perfect
stranger on the telephone and
write a sexy story and give it
to them?
[laughter] Right?
We're not so surprised.
So what we have to do,
of course, is take it in to the
lab and do this in a more
systematic way with random
assignment.
And this is how I'll want to
finish up today.
We have until 2:45,3:45?
Okay.
Great.
I'll take about five more
minutes to finish up and that'll
give us some time for questions.
So how do you do this in the
lab?
Well, you can bring people in
to the lab and I can present you
with a confederate who--Let's
say you are all in condition
one,
everybody on this side of the
room, and I can say to all of
you, "Please wait here.
We'll begin the experiment in a
moment.
While you're waiting please
fill out this form."
And the form includes how
attractive--how attracted you
are to the experimenter,
to me.
I can do the same thing over
here.
I can give you the form and ask
you to rate how attractive you
think I am and I can give you
the same instruction with a
crucial difference:
"Please wait here.
We will begin the painful shock
experiment in a moment.
Please fill out these forms
while you wait."
What happens?
The people who got the painful
shock instruction are more
likely to find the confederate
attractive.
[laughter] Why?
While they're sitting there
thinking about painful shock
it's making their heart beat
faster,
it's making their palms sweat,
it's making them breathe harder
maybe.
And even though it's fairly
obvious what's doing that,
they still misattribute that
arousal to "I must be falling in
love,"
even with that obvious a--even
with that obvious an
instruction.
You can do this in other ways.
You can bring--Here is one of
my favorite ones.
You bring people in the lab.
We'll make them the control
group this time.
We bring you in the--to the lab
and we say to this group of
people, "Please wait here.
We'll begin the experiment in a
moment.
You can fill out these forms in
the meantime."
The forms ask how attracted you
are to the experimenter.
You're now in the experimental
group and I say,
"Please wait here.
We'll begin the experiment in a
moment.
I'm going to ask you to fill
out some forms but first,
to get ready for this
experiment,
I'd like you to get on this
treadmill and run for ten
minutes."
So you've run on the treadmill.
You've just sat around.
The people who've run on the
treadmill, even when that
arousal is fairly obvious,
you've got--you--doing a little
bit of aerobic exercise,
you still find the experimenter
more attractive.
Okay?
This is why the fourth floor of
Payne Whitney Gym is such a
dangerous place [laughter]
and I urge you as your dean to
be very careful there.
[laughter] Okay?
It's that combination of
aerobic exercise and spandex
[laughter]
that leads to trouble.
All right.
Now, here's the final
experiment and I apologize for
this.
It is a bit sexist in 2007
context, but let me explain.
And we could never do this--and
one could never do this
experiment today but let me go
through it with you and you'll
apologize for its--some of its
qualities.
In this experiment male
subjects were brought in to the
lab and they were asked to look
at centerfolds from
Playboy magazine.
So, these are essentially
photographs of naked women.
And they are wearing headphones
that amplify their heartbeat and
they are asked among other
things how attracted are they to
the centerfold photograph that
they're looking at.
So, maybe--I don't remember how
many they look at.
Maybe it's about 10.
So, these slides are coming up.
They've got the headphones on.
The headphones are amplifying
their heartbeat and the slides
are moving one after another for
a few seconds each slide and
they're listening to their
heartbeat.
Slide one.
Slide two.
Slide three.
Slide four.
Slide five.
Slide six.
And then they're asked which
one did you find most
attractive, which one are you
most attracted to?
"Oh, slide five, absolutely.
She's the woman I want to
marry."
[laughter] Right?
And what has happened is
they're using this bodily cue of
their heartbeat to infer that
that's who they find more
attractive.
Now, here is the twist.
They're not actually listening
to their heartbeat.
They're listening to a tape
recording of a heartbeat.
And the experimenter is back
there with the speed knob
[laughter]
and at random intervals he just
speeds up the tape of their
heart [laughter]
and then slows it down.
And it doesn't matter which
slide he speeds up the tape of
the heartbeat on,
that's the one the subject is
more likely to think is the
person of their dreams,
the person they're attracted to.
So even you can misattribute
real arousal.
You can even misattribute phony
arousal, arousal that isn't even
coming from your body.
It's just coming--It's just
being played to you randomly.
You can even misattribute that.
Okay.
I think these experiments are
cute and I think there's an
interesting phenomenon there.
And it says something,
in a way, about how easily we
can be misled as to what things
in our environment,
even things coming from our own
body, mean.
But there's also some very
serious implications of this
kind of work.
One of them has to do with
domestic violence.
So think about domestic
violence situations and why
people stay in them.
Why do people stay in
relationships that are violent?
Now the number one reason,
and we have to acknowledge it
up front, is usually
economically there's no
alternative or people believe
there's no alternative.
"I can't leave because if I
leave I'd be homeless.
If I leave I will starve,
if my--if I leave my kids will
starve or there'll be danger to
my kids."
And that keeps people trapped
in abusive relationships
but--And that's number one,
but what else might be going
on?
Sometimes people don't realize
that the relationship they're in
is abusive--it's psychologically
or emotionally abusive.
They get into these fights and
screaming matches and
name-calling and such even if
it's not physical violence.
And they feel a certain arousal
when that happens and they
misattribute it.
"Well, he wouldn't be yelling
and screaming at me if he didn't
love me."
Right?
They misattribute that,
what might be anger,
what might even be aggression
and violence,
to an expression of love.
I have a friend who's a social
psychologist who told me a story
once that really made me very
nervous, although she's fine.
She said, "When I was dating my
husband"--this is thirty years
ago--"we were having a tough
time.
We were in many,
many arguments--We got into
many, many arguments and one
time something happened where he
came up to my car in a parking
lot and he was yelling at me
through the window.
And I rolled up the window and
before you know it he had
punched out the window."
And yelling at her and punched
out the window.
He didn't touch her.
And he--she said to me,
"That's when I knew he really
loved me."
And I thought that's scary and
I--and, all joking aside,
that's scary but that's
misattributed arousal.
"I'm feeling--when he did that
I felt something and I assumed
it was love.
What she was misattributing as
love--Well, she was
misattributing his aggressive
response as love.
She was misattributing her own
fear as mutual attraction,
as "And I must love him."
So, although we joke about
these kinds of experiments,
and they are fun to talk about
because they are unusual and
cute,
there is also some serious
implications of this kind of
work that one might think about.
And you might think about other
possible implications as well.
Okay.
Let me stop there and see what
kinds of questions we might
have.
[applause]
Dean Peter Salovey:
Thank you.
Thanks very much.
That's very kind of you.
Because we are on tape I'll
repeat any questions that come
in.
Yeah.
Student: [inaudible]
Dean Peter Salovey:
Right.
So the question is in
experiments like the painful
shock experiment if you are told
in advance,
like you all are,
through a consent form or by
the experimenter,
"This is an experiment
involving painful shock,"
will you still rate the
experimenter as more attractive
or will you not be able to
misattribute the arousal?
It is true.
The more salient we make the
source of the arousal,
the less likely you can get the
effect.
If in my thought experiment I
say to my friend,
"Well, I know why you're
feeling that way.
The reason why you're feeling
that way is ‘cause the barista
made a mistake and gave you
caffeinated espresso when you
asked for decaf or maybe you
just love me."
Right.
The person is not likely to
say, "Oh, I bet it's love."
They're more likely to think
oh, caffeine,
yeah.
That's the parsimonious
explanation here."
So it is true.
The more salient you make the
cause of the arousal,
the less likely you'll get the
effect but you can see even in
experiments where the cause of
the arousal is somewhat obvious,
at least to us,
you can still get a
misattribution effect.
Other questions.
Yes.
Student: [inaudible]
Dean Peter Salovey:
Yeah.
So the question is are any of
these factors,
particularly the big three,
proximity,
familiarity,
and similarity--Do they affect
the maintenance of relationships
or just the initial attraction?
It's interesting.
My guess is they affect both
initial and maintenance over
time but the literature mostly
focuses on initial attraction,
much richer data on that
initial attraction and those
initial stages of the
relationship in part because
it's a little hard to follow
couples over time.
Imagine the sort of
Heisenberg-esque problems we
would get carefully following
romantic couples over time and
interfering with them to ask
questions and make observations.
It would be hard to let this
couple naturally--this
relationship naturally unfold.
So, we really get--So,
really the focus of many of
these experiments is on initial
attraction.
That's why I always say my
lecture is on love,
the definition of terms is
about love,
but the experiments really are
much more about attraction than
about love.
Another question.
Yes.
Student: Can someone
feel consummate love for more
than one person?
Dean Peter Salovey: Oh.
Can someone feel consummate
love for more than one person?
That's a very good question.
It's actually a question that's
debated in the literature.
I didn't get into it at all in
this experiment--in this
lecture--but there's an
interesting debate going on
about love and many other
emotions between people who take
a kind of evolutionary
perspective on these states
versus people who take what
might be called a more socially
constructed perspective.
And these aren't necessarily so
incompatible but the
evolutionary perspective I think
would argue that you can feel
that kind of love for more than
one person or at least it would
facilitate the passing on of
your genetic material to a
larger array of the next
generation.
So I think the evolutionary
explanation is not a problem but
we have constructed a world
where in most societies,
except for very unusual
polygamist societies,
the belief is that you can't
love more than one.
Right.
And so you've got this tension
between what might be
evolutionarily wired impulses
and the kind of social
constraints that say this isn't
good,
this isn't appropriate,
this is taboo.
And my guess is the result is
yes, you could but you're not
going to feel un-conflicted
about it and it's because these
two are conflicting each other
at the same time.
How about one more question and
then we'll let you go?
I'm sorry.
I saw him first.
Student: Wouldn't
natural selection favor the
people who learn all these
things and then practically try
to apply them?
Dean Peter Salovey: So
he's making the evolutionary
argument.
Wouldn't natural selection
favor the people who take
introductory psychology,
come to my Valentine's Day
lecture, listen carefully to the
big three and the more
interesting four,
and then go out there and put
them into practice?
It feels a little bit like
the--like we're trying to pass
on an acquired characteristic,
which is a little bit counter
to Darwinian theory but if
somehow you could design a
proclivity for learning this
kind of material,
evolution might indeed favor it.
I can tell you this much.
It would make the several
thousands social psychologists
in this world very happy and
proud of their field,
if that turned out to be true.
Anyway, thank you all very much.
Happy Valentine's Day!
Thanks!